au début de ma transition et au milieu
j'ai tout de suite compris que la femme
trans était vue comme un fantasme
j'avais des propositions très très
étranges de garçons
bonjour je m'appelle Nina j'ai 25 ans
bonjour je m'appelle Jérémy j'ai 24 ans
je suis en couple avec les femmes
transjour alors moi quand j'étais petit
on peut dire quand j'étais bah petit
garçon forcément bah au début pendant ma
vraiment petit enfant je m'en rendais
vraiment pas compte encore de cette
souffrance donc j'ai grandi on va dire
normalement malgré que j'ai toujours été
très efféminé que j'ai dansé sur les L5
et que je mettais les talons de ma mère
mais c'est vraiment en grandissant vers
le début de l'adolescence 10-13 ans que
j'ai commencé vraiment à me poser des
questions à voilà voir mon apparence
changer les poils poussés enfin j'étais
je commençais vraiment à ne pas être à
l'aise avec mon corps et avec moi-même
et c'est surtout cette attirance envers
les garçons que j'avais mais que je ne
ressentais pas que j'étais gay c'est à
ce moment là que j'ai vraiment compris
qu'il y avait un réel problème et c'est
vrai que j'étais attiré par les garçons
mais je regardais aussi énormément les
femmes mais je regardais énormément les
femmes pas parce que je les désirais
mais parce qu'en fait je les prenais
comme exemple j'avais envie d'être une
femme et forcément maman mon exemple
dans ma vie ça a été ma maman et ma sœur
j'ai toujours été attiré par les femmes
jamais cliquer sur ma sexualité et
jamais attiré par les hommes quand Nina
mais tombé dessus et ben c'est sûr qu'il
y avait des questionnements parce que
voilà elle avait pas son adéquat elle
avait elle avait pas en fait elle est
pas encore fait son son changement de ça
on peut dire ça comme ça tu avais encore
le nom juste c'est sûr que je me suis
posé des questions ça a l'adolescence
vraiment que j'ai compris que j'étais
pas né dans le bon corps parce que
j'avais cette attirance envers les
garçons mais je voulais que le garçon me
voyais comme une fille et en plus
j'étais attiré que par les hommes hétéro
donc forcément il y avait un Big Mac
dans tout ça qu'il fallait comprendre et
régler quoi j'ai entamé les démarches
j'ai entamé mon parcours à l'âge de 17
ans et je l'ai fini l'année dernière
quand j'ai fait ma machine noblesse à 25
ans je connaissais Lina via son profil
Instagram je connaissais pas de son
histoire c'est pas du tout quand elle
était qui a été trans donc du coup je
lui ai envoyé un message parce que je
savais qu'il était sur Nice mais c'est
assez drôle parce que je lui ai demandé
on peut te croiser où et à ma gentiment
répondu je suis un croisable de là on a
commencé un peu à discuter on s'est vu
pour la première fois au bout d'une
semaine à son travail et c'est de là
qu'après on a entamé les discussions les
plus sérieuses là où tu m'as dit
directement que tu étais femme trans
physiquement déjà elle avait déjà une
bonne base faut dire s'il faut dire elle
avait rien enfin elle avait rien encore
fait sur son visage pas de finalisation
faciale du coup moi quand je l'ai vu
vraiment j'ai vu une femme donc non je
me suis pas posé la question sur quoi il
est venu me voir à mon travail sur le
moment il avait pas du tout remarqué
j'étais une femme trans mais moi j'ai
tout de suite voulu lui dire que voilà
j'ai pas toujours été comme ça
physiquement que j'étais né garçon parce
que je voulais pas m'attacher à un
garçon si après je savais que ça allait
mener nulle part par rapport à ma
différence j'étais pas encore opéré
j'avais encore mon pénis je vais
directement dit je lui ai dit voilà
comment tu prends la chose je préfère
être clair avec toi et il m'a dit de
toute façon est-ce que tu comptes
l'enlever donc moi je dis oui oui j'ai
déjà j'attends ma date d'opération et il
m'a dit bah si tu comptes te faire
opérer alors pour moi c'est OK et au
moment du coup j'ai dû lui annoncer bah
je me suis retrouvé face à quelqu'un en
fait qui a voulu apprendre à me
connaître qui a voulu apprendre mon
histoire qui avait pas de cliché qui m'a
qui m'a pas sexualisé et qui m'a vu
comme un fantasme et c'est ça déjà qui a
fait que j'ai eu un énorme coup de coeur
pour ce garçon et parce que je me suis
vraiment senti femme et pas vu comme un
en fait parce que c'est vrai que la
femme trans c'est énormément sexualisé
dans la société et du coup bah moi voilà
je lui ai dit je lui ai expliqué mon
histoire et puis après bah j'ai dû lui
dire que forcément j'étais pas opéré que
j'avais encore mon piste si ni non
n'avait pas n'avait pas fait son
opération je pense que je serai pas
rester avec elle parce que je suis pas
attiré par texte d'un homme fait cette
cru mais il sait pas ce qui m'excite moi
j'ai toujours côtoyé une femme donc
avoir des rapports avec le d'un homme à
me dire rien ça me fait rien forcément
c'était difficile les premiers temps
parce que moi je suis resté un an et
demi avec mon pénis j'avais pas encore
mon sexe de femme donc du coup bah
pendant un an et demi c'est vrai que
pour nos relations sexuelles c'était
quand même assez compliqué et surtout
pour Jérémy et il a vraiment été très
courageux vis-à-vis de ça on a toujours
trouvé notre plaisir mutuellement tout
en restant dans la zone de confort de
chacun parce que moi forcément j'avais
pas le bon spectacle adéquat donc moi je
voulais pas être frustré ou quoi que ce
soit ça c'est plutôt quand même bien
passé et au bout d'un an et demi je me
suis fait opérer et après bah c'était le
bonheur quoi j'ai bien vécu après aussi
une part de filtre de frustration parce
que après j'avais pas aussi j'étais pas
épanoui à 100% donc j'ai du m'adapter
j'ai beaucoup d'attentes mais finalement
après quand c'est fait opérer écoute
l'attente était payante alors être une
femme trans en 2023 c'est sûr que c'est
pas tout le temps facile mais je pense
que c'est pas facile pour celles qui
n'assume pas vraiment ou qui apporte de
l'importance à l'incompréhension des
gens moi c'est pas mon cas c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs je me suis lancé sur TikTok
c'est pour vraiment casser un peu les
préjugés et partager informer et éduquer
sur le sujet parce qu'il y a encore trop
de gens qui pensent qu'une femme trans
est un travelo ce qui n'est absolument
pas le cas moi pour ma part c'est simple
d'être une femme transgenre dans le sens
où moi j'assume mon parcours j'assume
mon histoire j'en parle donc je me suis
trouvé et quand dans la vie on s'est
trouvé et qu'on s'assume à 100%, il y a
rien qui peut nous atteindre au niveau
du regard des gens c'est vrai que depuis
que j'ai fini mes opérations très
honnêtement bon après c'est vrai que je
suis grande j'ai quand même une sacrée
carrure mais bon je suis une femme ronde
mais comme plein de femmes rondes aussi
c'est pas forcément des femmes trans
mais je veux dire c'est sûr que voilà je
fais pas
[Musique]
de reconnaître des fois dans la rue il y
a personne qui est venu nous voir en
face qui m'a dit espèce de sa transe toi
tu es un gay c'est même le contraire il
y a que des bons gens qui viennent vers
nous donc en vrai il faut se mettre une
barrière les réseaux c'est les réseaux
et la réalité c'est la réalité je tenais
à rebondir aussi et généralement les
gens qui critiquent aussi les gens qui
l'assument pas ou qu'ils ont déjà eu des
problèmes en Thaïlande en vacances donc
moi ma transition en tout elle a pris 6
ans donc j'ai commencé ma transition en
2017 donc quand je dis j'ai commencé ma
transition 2017 c'est qu'en fait j'ai
commencé à ne plus aller chez le
coiffeur donc à ne plus me couper les
cheveux et à m'inscrire à l'hôpital
public donc à Lyon il y a un service qui
s'appelle le gritty ce qui prennent en
charge les personnes trans donc moi
c'est par là que je suis passé parce
qu'à l'époque j'habitais à Lyon et donc
du coup donc j'ai commencé en 2017 et
c'est un long et périlleux parcours très
très long parce que j'ai choisi aussi de
passer par le public pourquoi j'ai
décidé de passer par public tout
simplement parce que j'avais le droit à
une nail d donc c'est un 100% et grâce à
ce parcours j'ai eu le droit à toutes
les opérations remboursées la sécurité
sociale mais du coup il y a quand même
un long protocole à respecter pour avoir
ces opérations remboursées donc il y a
plein de rendez-vous psychiatres il y a
des rendez-vous psy après il y a une
commission entre les médecins je devais
rendre à mémoire de 10 pages pour
expliquer pourquoi je voulais changer de
sexe et une fois que les médecins
passent en commission et disent oui ou
non en généralement c'est souvent oui à
part quand il trouve que la personne est
trop fragile psychologiquement ou qui a
le quel change pas pour les bonnes
raisons ils disent non mais pour ma part
en tout cas c'était oui et donc du coup
si qu'une fois qu'ils acceptent cette
commission qu'on peut commencer les
hormones et les opérations donc moi j'ai
commencé les hormones en 2018 j'ai
changé aussi le prénom en 2018
et j'ai fait mes premières opérations en
2020 donc j'ai fait une féminisation
faciale et une augmentation mammaire en
même temps c'est horrible donc une
féminisation faciale c'est quoi c'est
tout simplement qu'on va venir en fait
modifier
le visage mais en passant par squelette
c'est à dire qu'on m'a ouvert donc tout
le front m'a attiré la peau on m'a limé
les arcades sourcilières on m'a cassé
des morceaux d'eau pour en fait adoucir
le visage et casser mes traits masculins
et les rendre plus féminins j'ai fait
une rhinoplastie après je fais des
augmentations aux lèvres et j'ai fait la
poitrine et en 2022 donc l'année
dernière j'ai fait mon changement de
texte donc une vaginoplastie donc ça
consiste tout simplement à transformer
un pénis en vagin en faisant tout
simplement une ablation des testicules
et après on modifie le pénis on le
rentre enfin ça c'est toutes les
techniques du chirurgien mais pour qu'au
final bah ça ressemble vraiment à un
vagin je pense que tu peux le témoigner
le clitoris c'est un morceau du gland et
en fait il y a vraiment toutes les
sensations qui sont conservés c'est
vraiment extraordinaire ce qu'ils
peuvent faire donc moi c'est vrai que
j'ai fait la féminisation faciale et la
poitrine en même temps donc c'est vrai
que la féminisation faciale ça reste
quand même une opération très lourde
dans le sens où ben on va venir toucher
quand même le crâne le squelette etc
donc forcément on va gonfler on va avoir
des hémates de partout et vu que j'ai
fait les deux en même temps c'était
quand même très intense franchement si
je devrais le refaire je pense que je le
referai en deux fois parce que pour vous
dire j'ai moins eu mal à la en bas que
en haut c'était vraiment ma pire
opération c'était vraiment le visage
malgré le ce qui on peut penser qui qui
peut être lourd franchement moi c'était
vraiment pas du tout ma pire opération
alors être en couple avec une femme
trans alors je vais rebondir sur ce que
tu as dit alors c'est vrai qu'au début
avant de avant ces opérations c'est
qu'il y avait beaucoup de regards et
fallait vraiment affronter ça et pas et
pas calculé parce que faut dire faut
dire qu'on a eu beaucoup de beaucoup de
moments où vraiment ça a été c'était dur
pour moi qu'est-ce que ça c'est tout
nouveau pour moi aussi donc fallait que
accepte c'était un changement radical
dans ma vie et aussi le fait que voilà
j'ai que c'est accepté de m'exposer avec
sur les réseaux avec toi c'était aussi
pour faire passer aussi un message et
sans sensibiliser beaucoup plus de
personnes et dire que voilà on peut être
on peut être heureux avec une avec une
personne différente et arrêter de mettre
des gens dans les cases et accepter
laisser les gens vivre comme ils veulent
vivre en fait et j'espère vraiment voilà
avoir passé un message et aussi voilà
montrer aussi que on peut être heureux
avec une femme trans et on peut vivre
une une vie comme un couple normal dans
la vie de tous les jours aller faire ses
courses avoir un chien et vie de famille
donc moi tu donnes confiance
et puis même si vous regardez cette
vidéo s'il y a des personnes qui
regardent cette vidéo qui sont dans le
même cas que moi et qui osent pas même
s'exprimer ou faire leur coming out à
leur famille foncer ne vivez pas pour
les autres vous savez où faut pas avoir
de regrets dans la vie c'est pas avec
votre famille malheureusement vous allez
faire votre vie mais c'est que la
personne à qui vous êtes voilà après
j'ai toujours été attiré par les femmes
je me suis jamais cliqué sur ma
sexualité et jamais attirée par les
hommes et
quand Nina est tombé dessus et ben c'est
sûr qu'il y a eu des questionnements
parce que voilà elle avait pas son sexe
adéquat je l'ai bien vécu après aussi
une part de fustre de frustration parce
que après j'avais pas aussi j'étais pas
épanoui à 100% donc j'ai du m'adapter
j'ai dû c'était aussi
long beaucoup d'attentes mais finalement
après quand c'est fait opérer bah écoute
l'attente a été payante
j'ai pas attendu pour rien alors c'est
vrai que depuis que je me suis lancé sur
Tik Tok donc ça va faire un an et que
maintenant je vis de ça c'est vrai que
bah automatiquement bah il y a pas que
les bons côtés il y a aussi toutes les
critiques moi personnellement les
critiques j'en prends pas compte parce
que je pars du principe que de toute
façon dans la vie quoi qu'on fasse on
sera toujours jugé là les gens ils
aiment bien un peu prendre ils pensent
en fait que c'est une faiblesse mais en
fait moi c'est ma force c'est une femme
trans donc ça m'attend pas et Jérémy
c'est pareil il assume la relation tout
son entourage est au courant et le
soutien donc en fait ces gens là ils ont
aucun impact dans notre bonheur et en
plus c'est des gens généralement qui eux
ne sont même pas heureux eux-mêmes donc
en fait c'est juste de la méchanceté
gratuite quoi donc nous ça nous
franchement je sais pas pour toi mais
pour moi en tout cas ça m'attend
absolument pas non plus donc et moi pour
la suite ce que je nous souhaite bah
j'aimerais bien qu'on se marie il est
pas encore prêt mais moi c'est vraiment
mon rêve de petite fille et après bah je
nous souhaite d'être heureux encore
comme on l'est et de réussir encore plus
professionnellement et voilà d'être
heureux tout simplement